this beautiful building behind me is
Amrish leghole which is home to
Electrical and Computer Engineering an
interesting aspect of Hammerstein Hall
is the rotunda up top
which is actually a cleverly disguised
smokestack originally when the campus
was built we were too far away from
downtown Pittsburgh to hook up to their
power grid we had to fuel our own campus
so it was a requirement that all
freshmen had to shovel two weeks worth
of coal in order to graduate and an
interesting twist of fate these dirty
coal rooms turned into 97 to 99 percent
Dustin particle free clean rooms and are
where we manufacture a lot of our
computer hardware and computer chips
Hammerstein calls student-created living
roof is one of Carnegie Mellon's many
green initiatives on campus the roof
serves to reduce stormwater runoff
conserve energy and also to protect the
roof from the sun's harmful UV rays